und bei mir ist Ricarda lang die
Bundesvorsitzende der Grünen Frau lang
wie sehr hat denn die Diskussion auf
Bundesebene über die heizungstauschpläne
und auch die trauzeugenaffäre aus dem
grünen Wirtschaftsministerium den Bremer
Wahlkämpfern geschadet vielleicht
erstmal zu dem Bremer Wahlergebnis
selbst das ist klar das Ergebnis ist uns
enttäuschend unsere Leute in Bremen
haben in den letzten Jahren
Verantwortung genommen haben dort viel
rausgeholt was Finanzpolitik angeht was
Sozialpolitik angeht was Klimaschutz
angeht aber es ist anscheinend nicht
gelungen dass inhaltliche Angeboten auch
das Erreichte in ausreichend Maßen die
Breite zu kommunizieren und so Wähler
Stimmen zu gewinnen es ist für uns
enttäuschen und wir werden das jetzt
gemeinsam mit dem Landesverband
aufarbeiten aber wie ist denn ihre
Analyse der Anteil der Bundespartei also
sie als Regierungspartei unter
Dauerbeschuss was die heizungspläne
anbelangt maßgeblich im Grünen
Wirtschaftsministerium mit ausgearbeitet
und auch jetzt die trauzeugen-affäre wie
groß ist der Anteil das hat in Bremen im
Wahlkampf eine Rolle gespielt ich glaube
es ist offensichtlich dass der bunten
letzten Wochen wenig Rücken Halt gegeben
hat irgendwie nicht Rückenwind gegeben
hat wir sehen dass wir uns ent haben
nicht weit und eine Politik zu machen
womit Blick auf die nächsten
Landtagswahlen und der nächsten Umfragen
man notwendige Veränderungen einfach
immer weiter aufschiebt gleichzeitig
sehen wir aber auch dass sie um einen
spezifische Situationen des
Landesverbandes geht denn das Bremer
Ergebnis liegt nochmal deutlich unter
dem Bundestrend und es gab auch viele
Themen die landesspezifisch waren die
dort die Debatte geprägt haben und wo
wir es leider das muss man zu ehrlich
sagen nicht geschafft haben in die
Breite auszustrahlen das war dann
Kampagne die darauf angelegt war aber am
Ende ist das nicht gelungen die grüne
Spitzenkandidatinnen in Bremen Michael
Schäfer hat trotzdem gesagt sie sei im
Wahlkampf immer damit konfrontiert
gewesen mit den
heizungstauschplänen in im Bund das sei
durchaus ein großes Thema gewesen es ist
ihnen in den letzten Wochen nicht
gelungen diese Diskussion zu entschärfen
das geht zu lassen von Robert Habeck und
auch zu Lasten der Grünen Partei warum
ist es ihnen nicht gelungen da mehr zu
erklären und dann Kommunikations- und
erklärt Defizit aufzuholen ich glaube
wir sind gerade dabei sehr viel zu
erklären das wichtigste was meiner Sicht
auch wenn ich unterwegs war egal wo
Wahlkampf ist das die Frage die die
Menschen am meisten umtreibt und das ist
die soziale Flankierung wir haben jetzt
noch mal einen Vorschlag gemacht wir
wollen das für Menschen mit geringen
Einkommen bis zu 80 Prozent der Kosten
für eine neue Wärmepumpe genommen wollen
für die Menschen mit einem zu
versteuernden Einkommen von bis zu
60.000 Euro sollen uns immer in 40
Prozent sein ich glaube hier ist es
wichtig dass wir jetzt einen Schritt
vorangehen da warte ich auch dass unsere
Koalitionspartner mitgehen denn wir alle
wissen wir verändern gerade viel als
Ampelkoalition das wird nur gelingen
wenn wir sozial abfedern wenn wir
soziale Sicherheit bieten und das ist
jetzt doch die notwendige Aufgabe vor
der bestehen das grüne
Wirtschaftsministerium macht es im
Moment den Kritikern auch einfach in der
trauzeugenaffäre um den Staatssekretär
Patrick reichen sind Fehler eingestanden
worden auch von Robert Habeck allerdings
gibt es keine Konsequenzen wie wollen
Sie denn dem Eindruck entgegentreten
dass bei den Grünen in der
Personalpolitik nicht nur Qualifikation
sondern auch Parteibuch und persönliche
Verbindung zählen hier muss man sehr
klar unterscheiden es gibt den einen
Bereich wo ein Fehler gemacht wurde das
haben auch alle eingestanden hier ist
Kritik auch berechtigt und hier gibt es
natürlich eine Konsequenz das Verfahren
wird neu aufgesetzt ist und neu
aufgeschrieben und es wird auch eine
neue Person gefunden werden daneben gibt
es einige Punkte wo man das Gefühl hat
das jetzt auch etwas weitreichende
Verbindung aufgemacht werden wenn ich
share PC wo von einem Paten gesprochen
wird dann ist das ehrlich gesagt
ziemlich absurd für uns ist wichtig wir
halten uns an Compliance regeln das ist
ganz klar das ist der Grundsatz ich
denke nicht nur grüne Politik sondern
soll der Grundsatz aller Politik sein
wir gestehen Fehler ein da wo sie
gemacht wurden wir räumen danach auf
dass es an dieser Stelle passiert und
jetzt geht es darum nach vorne zu
schauen und ich will vielleicht an der
Stelle auch einmal sagen weil es jetzt
viel und das Wirtschaftsministerium ging
dass wir im letzten Jahr so gut durch
den Winter gekommen sind trotz all den
Unken rufen die es gab die
Energieversorgung wird knapp werden wir
werden eine Wirtschaftskrise haben das
liegt auch ganz besonderes an der Arbeit
von Robert Habeck und ich glaube wir
sind alle froh dass wir heute so da
stehen wir da stehen
die Erfolge können Sie rausstellen die
Fehler trotzdem erklären das gehört dazu
vielen Dank
danke Ihnen